bonjour à tous j'espère que vous allez
bien on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour la
vidéo faq cinquante mille abonnés
cinquante mille abonnés c'est juste
extraordinaire
jamais je n'aurais cru qu'on atteindrait
ce nombre d'abonnés sur cette chaîne
donc merci infiniment merci du fond du
coeur pour votre soutien je suis
vraiment très sensible à la manière dont
vous me soutenez que ce soit en
partageant les vidéos en laissant un
pouce en les commentant j'en profite
d'ailleurs pour remercier également
toutes les personnes qui me soutiennent
financièrement sur tipi parce que c'est
grâce à votre soutien financier que je
peux libérer du temps pour réaliser ces
vidéos c'est grâce à votre soutien
financier que je peux aussi faire des
déplacements comme par exemple pour
l'entretien avec jean pierre petit j'ai
pu libérer une journée travaillée faire
le déplacement jusqu'à chez lui à aix en
provence et sans votre soutien tout ça
ne serait tout simplement pas possible
donc merci infiniment à vous alors pour
cette faq vous avez été très nombreux à
m'envoyer vos questions donc je vous le
dit d'entrée de jeu je ne pourrai
malheureusement pas répondre à toutes
les questions parce que sinon bah il
faudrait que je réponde à chaque
question or à peine quelques secondes et
vous le savez c'est pas mon genre je
suis plutôt quelqu'un de bavards donc je
vais prendre le temps de développer
chacune de mes réponses
donc désolé à tous ceux dont je n'ai pas
sélectionner la question vous aurez
d'autres occasions peut-être
prochainement la vidéo faq cent mille
abonnés on ne sait jamais si vous
continuez à à me soutenir ça arrivera
peut-être plus vite qu'on ne le pense
en attendant on y va pour les questions
de cette vidéo c'est parti je ne connais
pas grand chose en philosophie mais j'ai
toujours été intéressé dans la prendre
plus alors la question est quelle
hauteur ou quel livre meurent comment tu
pour commencer alors ça c'est vraiment
la question classique qu'on me pose très
souvent dans les commentaires
par quel livre commence et la
philosophie alors moi j'ai envie de
répondre à cette question qu'il n'y a
pas de règle
en réalité on peut commencer par lire
des extraits on peut commencer par lire
des ouvrages de vulgarisation on peut
même commencer par lire des lexiques de
philosophie pour se familiariser avec
les grands concepts et puis il ya une
autre alternative c'est le petit livre
de vulgarisation que j'ai écrit
justement pour répondre à toutes les
personnes qui souhaitent s'initier à la
philosophie
alors ce livre vous le trouverez
désormais gratuitement dans sa version
pdf
sur mon site internet donc
www.leprogres.fr vous avez le lien dans
la description il vous suffit tout
simplement de cliquer sur cadeau de
bienvenue de laisser votre email et vous
recevrez gratuitement ce petit livre de
vulgarisation philosophique qui
s'appelle tous philosophes point
d'interrogation et dans lequel je
m'amuse à analyser philosophiquement dix
phrases de la vie quotidienne en mettant
à chaque fois une référence précise à un
auteur ou un mouvement philosophique
voilà pour la réponse à cette question à
quel âge as tu découvert la philosophie
as-tu toujours eu envie d'enseigner la
philosophie aux autres alors j'ai
découvert la philosophie réellement à
l'âge de 17 ans quand je suis entré en
terminale mais en réalité on peut dire
que je pratiquais déjà la philosophie à
un niveau personnel et amateurs parce
que pendant l'adolescence j'étais déjà
très attiré par le questionnement par la
métaphysique par les questions
existentielles comme on dirait et une
certaine manière j'ai mais la
philosophie avant même de savoir que la
philosophie existait donc c'est quelque
chose qui m'a toujours animé puisque de
toute façon la philosophie je la définit
d'abord comme une attitude comme une
disposition d'esprit
la philosophie pour moi c'est le fait de
s'interroger devant quelque chose qui à
priori ne présente pas de mystère ne
présentent pas d'énigme c'est le fait de
toujours aller au delà des apparences de
ne pas se satisfaire de la surface des
choses
vouloir toujours approfondir questionner
interrogé plus que répondre d'ailleurs
puisque le propre de la philosophie
c'est qu'il est très difficile
d'apporter des réponses définitives
donc voilà comment s'est passée la
rencontre avec la philosophie pendant
mon adolescence
le questionnement est est ce que j'ai
toujours eu envie d'enseigner la
philosophie aux autres pas du tout en
réalité je n'avais pas la vocation pour
devenir enseignant j'ai toujours eu
l'impression que je n'étais pas légitime
pour transmettre des connaissances
toujours souffert de ce syndrome de
l'imposteur qui fait qu' on a
l'impression qu'on n'est pas compétent
qu'on n'a pas là la prétention de
transmettre des choses aux autres est en
réalité c'est quand j'ai commencé à
donner des cours et au début c'était
surtout pour arrondir mes fins de mois
pendant mes études
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai constater
l'écart qu'il y avait entre toutes les
connaissances que j'avais accumulé
pendant mes études et le niveau de mes
élèves
que j'avais des élèves qui était en
terminale et par la force des choses
j'avais beaucoup plus de connaissances
que et surtout j'avais cette capacité à
les transmettre de manière simple et
concrète et c'est ça qui a fait
d'ailleurs que ce métier a commencé à me
plaire c'est à dire que je me suis rendu
compte tout simplement que j'étais un
bon pédagogue que j'arrivais à ramener
des choses complexes à des formes
beaucoup plus simple et parce que
j'avais des retours positifs de mes
élèves
j'ai continué j'ai persisté je me suis
amélioré dans l'enseignement et d'une
certaine manière c'est ça qui m'a
conduit à faire des vidéos aujourd'hui
sur youtube
question suivante quelle philosophie
s'apparente plus à celle qui est la
tienne au quotidien alors ça c'est une
bonne question je vais quand même faire
une précision avant d'y répondre c'est
que je fais partie de ceux qui ne
considèrent pas la philosophie comme une
sorte de boîte à outils dans laquelle on
pourrait piocher un petit peu ce dont on
a besoin selon la situation
il semble vraiment que la philosophie
c'est pas ça la philosophie c'est tout
un processus d'évolution d'évolution
personnelle de sa pensée de sa manière
de raisonner de sa manière d'envisager
les problèmes et on peut pas vraiment
dire que j'utilise une philosophie dans
ma vie quotidienne
en réalité je suis façonné par toute la
philosophie que j'ai étudié depuis mon
adolescence et ce serait un petit peu
artificielle que de dire que je n'aspire
surtout d'une philosophie
mais si je devais quand même donné une
réponse concrète à cette question et
pour ceux qui me connaissent ça ne vous
surprendra pas je dirais que la
philosophie qui m'accompagne le plus au
quotidien c'est le stoïcisme
évidemment c'est le stoïcisme parce que
comme je le dis dans ma vidéo sur ce
sujet c'est une philosophie pratique
autant que théorique
et quand on pratique le stoïcisme on
arrive à faire preuve d'un certain
détachement vis-à-vis des choses qui en
temps normal nous affecterait nous
affecterait peut-être même nous
troublerait nous perturberait au
quotidien donc pour ma part lorsque je
suis confronté à une situation qui me
déplaît qui m'agace qui me dérange
j'arrive toujours à prendre le dessus
j'arrive toujours à me dire que ce n'est
pas si grave et que je ne dois pas être
affectés de ce qui ne dépend pas de moi
à ce que de toute façon ça ne ferait
qu'ajouter de la souffrance à la
souffrance
et je suis quelqu'un qui pense que la
souffrance ne doit pas être cultivée que
la souffrance est quelque chose qui nous
empêche d'avancer et pour ma part je
l'éliminé autant que possible voilà
j'espère t'avoir répondu question
suivante quelle est ta routine pour
t'organiser et instruire alors c'est
difficile de répondre à cette question
parce que je n'ai pas vraiment de
routine pour m'organiser je dirais
plutôt que l'organisation c'est quelque
chose que j'ai mis en place avec le
temps puisque au départ je suis
quelqu'un de très bordélique eu vraiment
pas quelqu'un d'organisé à la base et je
me suis rendu compte que si je
continuais à être désorganisé
je ne pourraient tout simplement pas
accomplir ce que je souhaite je ne
pourraient tout simplement pas atteindre
mes objectifs
et quand on se donne des objectifs
personnels des objectifs professionnels
on est obligé d'être organisés en
réalité c'est le secret c'est la base
absolue
si on veut être efficace si on veut être
productif et si on veut réussir
maintenant moi j'ai une méthode qui est
extrêmement simple et que j'ai le luxe
de pouvoir m'offrir c'est de travailler
sur des choses qui me plaisent et qui me
passionne et quand on est passionné par
ce qu'on fait dans son travail
en réalité le travail cesse d'être un
travail et c'est ce que je recommande
toujours à mes élèves je leur dis que
s'ils veulent réussir leur vie ils ne
doivent pas se poser la question de ce
que veut dire réussir au sens social
mais de ce que ça veut dire aux sources
personnelles et au sens personnel
réussir s'est réconcilié la contrainte
et la passion s'est réconcilié
l'obligation et le plaisir et si vous
vous lever tous les matins pour aller
faire quelque chose qui vous plaît c'est
à dire quelque chose que vous avez envie
de faire sans même qu'on ait besoin de
vous y forcer et bien c'est que vous
avez déjà réussi votre vie donc ma
méthode pour m'organiser m'instruire
c'est que j'aime mon travail c'est que
j'aime apprendre c'est que j'aime
transmettre et à partir de là je n'ai
plus besoin de faire d'effort question
suivante
as tu réussi à arrêter de fumer et en
quoi est ce important de prendre tout
aussi bien soin et de cultiver son corps
que son esprit oui j'ai réussi à arrêter
de fumer et j'ai arrêté de fumer en mars
2010 9 en mars de l'année dernière
alors je vais pas vous cacher que j'ai
quand même un substitut qui me permet
aussi
de tenir le coup mais j'ai arrêté de
fumer parce que j'ai repris le sport de
manière beaucoup plus sérieuses et
intensives l'année dernière et ça a
participé si vous voulez d'une évolution
générale c'est-à-dire que quand on pose
la question comment as tu fait pour
arrêter de fumer
je réponds je n'ai pas choisi d'arrêter
de fumer c'est le fait d'arrêter de
fumer qui m'a choisi et cette décision
en réalité ce n'est pas nous qui les
prenons c'est le contexte c'est la
situation ce sont les conditions qui
font qu'à un moment donné vous allez
avoir envie de franchir cette étape
donc quand certaines personnes me
demandent conseil pour savoir comment se
débarrasser d'une mauvaise habitude
je leur dis tout simplement ne te
débarrasses pas de ta mauvaise habitude
remplace la part une autre ne te dis pas
que tu vas arrêter de fumer
dis toi que tu vas commencer à prendre
soin de son corps et de sa santé et pour
rejoindre la deuxième partie de la
question
prendre soin de son corps c'est à dire
s'entretenir physiquement pratiquer un
sport c'est quelque chose selon moi qui
est aussi important que cultiver son
esprit parce que il ya un gros
malentendu qui plane au dessus de la
philosophie qui consiste à dire que la
vie des idées serait plus importante que
la vie du corps mais c'est une mauvaise
manière de voir les choses puisque la
pensée a besoin du corps parce que la
philosophie ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui est détaché de la réalité
la philosophie ça sert à comprendre la
réalité et pour pouvoir comprendre la
réalité il faut déjà commencer par
l'accepter il faut commencer par en
prendre acte
la réalité c'est d'abord le monde
physique c'est d'abord la matérialité
qui s'offrent à notre regard en
permanence c'est l'avis du corps c'est
ce qui fait que tous les matins on a
traîné notre corps hors du lit on doit
lui usé par le travail le soir la
fatigue nous emporte
et tout ça ce sont des phénomènes
corporelle l'amitié le jeu l'amour la
joie tout ça ce sont des phénomènes qui
passe d'abord par le corps et l'esprit
ne doit pas renier malgré le corps
l'esprit doit régner en collaboration
avec le corps voilà pourquoi je mets un
point d'honneur à m'entretenir
physiquement à faire du sport à rester
dans l'effort physique
l'effort physique qui est bienfaiteur
pour l'esprit de toute façon parce qu'on
pense beaucoup mieux après avoir fait
une séance de sport après avoir couru
pendant une heure après avoir tapé dans
un sac que lorsqu'on est complètement
avachi nous comptons pas suite
sur son canapé à regarder netflix c'est
mon point de vue vous en faites ce que
vous voulez question suivante quel est
l'ennemi de la philosophie
alors je dirais que l'ennemi de la
philosophie c'est d'abord la certitude
parce que la certitude c'est ce qui vous
fait croire que votre pensée est
terminée c'est ce qui vous fait croire
que vous n'avez plus rien à apprendre
donc c'est bien le contraire de la
philosophie qui est une démarche
d'apprentissage permanent d'évolution et
de découverte permanente
d'ailleurs on remarquera que le mot
vérité en grec se disait aletheia et
aletheia voulait dire retrait du voile
c'est à dire que la vérité
c'est ce qui résulte d'un processus de
dévoilement de révélations et donc
accéder à la vérité ça suppose d'être
toujours en train d' ôter une partie du
voile le voile des apparences
autrement dit on n'arrive pas dans la
vérité par un bon parent sow la vérité
ce n'est pas un résultat c'est un
processus c'est un chemin et la
philosophie c'est apprendre de ses
erreurs
c'est apprendre de ses échecs c'est
apprendre de tout ce qui a fait qu'on
était dans le faux et lorsqu'on s'en
rend compte et lorsqu'on l'acceptent
c'est à dire que ça suppose une certaine
forme d'humilité envers soi lorsqu'on
accepte d'avoir été dans l'erreur ou de
s'être trompée et bien à ce moment-là
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
augmente c'est qu'on élargi notre champ
d'appréhension de la réalité est qu'on
devient finalement beaucoup plus
sensibles beaucoup plus éveiller au
monde parce qu'on arrive à percevoir des
informations qu'on n'avait pas su
percevoir avant tout simplement parce
que notre champ de perception était
limitée à notre opinion du moment et
qu'on considérait que on avait atteint
le savoir définitif question suivante
salut ma question c'est pourquoi quand
je parle philosophiquement avec les gens
ils disent que je suis ce type qui
connaît tous et qui a toujours raison
ironiquement et ça me gêne vraiment
félicitations pour tes 50 mille abonnés
alors ça c'est encore une très bonne
question et j'ai peut-être je dis bien
peut-être un début de réponse c'est que
lorsqu'on est passionné par la
philosophie
lorsqu'on est animé par le
questionnement permanent et qu'on
s'intéresse à plein de sujets ça
développe généralement en haut une
tendance qui est de vouloir parler de ça
à tout le monde
c'est à dire qu'on va se retrouver en
soirée avec des amis ou même des
personnes qu'on qu'on va rencontrer pour
la première fois on va commencer à
parler avec elle et puis tout à coup on
va se mettre à leur parler de
philosophie on va se mettre à leur
parler de choses un petit peu sérieuse
et la plupart du temps les personnes qui
sont en soirée ou que vous rencontrez
comme ça dans un contexte de loisirs et
de détente n'ont pas envie de réfléchir
parce qu'elle associe la réflexion à la
prise de tête donc à l'effort et à la
souffrance
il faut bien comprendre que dans la
mesure du possible l'être humain en
société il essaye d'éviter il essaie de
minimiser l'effort puisqu'il produit
déjà de l'effort en travaillant
généralement quand on rentre du travail
on n'a pas forcément envie de parler
philosophie on n'a pas vraiment envie de
réfléchir au sens des concepts qu'on
entend et ça peut donner l'impression
que celui qui vient nous parler de
philosophie il est un petit peu en
boucle dans son délire il a un petit peu
bloqué sur ces raisonnements
l'abstraction le fait de citer des
auteurs généralement ce que ça produit
chez celui qui nous écoutent
c'est que ça passe pour de l'arrogance
ça passe pour du pédantisme ça passe
pour une manière de montrer qu'on sait
plein de choses qu'on est cultivé qu'on
a lu des livres et ça a un côté un petit
peu écrasant pour celui qui nous
écoutent
parce que quand vous êtes quelqu'un qui
n'a pas lu quand vous êtes quelqu'un qui
ne connaît pas la philosophie et et qui
n'a pas énormément de vocabulaire
philosophique
quand vous entendez quelqu'un qui vous
tient la jambe pendant deux heures pour
vous citer des noms de philosophes dont
vous avez vaguement entendu le nom il ya
des années mais que vous ne connaissez
rien au contenu leur pensée ça ne vous
intéresse pas parce que ça ne vous
concerne pas vous ne vous sentez pas
impliqué donc ça peut aussi expliquer
pourquoi quand on parle de philosophie à
quelqu'un cette personne là elle est
rétive ces personnes là elle est
récalcitrante
parce que ça ne m'intéresse pas elle ne
se sent pas concerné - le conseil que je
peux donner c'est quand tu parles de
philosophie ne dis pas que tu parles de
philosophie parle de sujets légers parle
de sujets concrets et surtout parle de
sujets qui intéressent la personne à qui
tu parles et essaye de donner une
dimension philosophique à ce que tu
racontes mais sans le dire explicitement
parce que dès que tu va prononcer le mot
de philosophie la personne elle va se
braquer directement donc par de
philosophie de manière subtile de
manière un pli
cit parce qu'après tout la philosophie
elle n'a pas besoin de s'afficher pour
être elle n'a pas besoin de se présenter
comme une discipline technique est
compliqué pour être réellement efficace
j'espère avoir répondu à ta question de
quoi ne discutez vous pas avec les
autres
comment supporter les conneries des
autres alors là on est presque dans le
prolongement de la question précédente
de quoi est-ce que je ne discute pas
avec les autres je ne discute pas de
politique avec les autres je ne discute
pas de religion avec les autres je ne
discute pas des sujets qui concernent
trop personnellement les personnes avec
qui je parle pour qu'on puisse avoir une
discussion rationnelle et sereine
en réalité quand vous voulez aborder des
sujets polémiques avec les gens dites
vous bien que vous allez vous adresser à
leurs émotions et quand vous vous
adressez aux émotions
vous ne pouvez plus avoir des changes au
niveau des idées
vous ne pouvez plus avoir de débat
rationnel c'est comme ça nous sommes des
êtres humains et ont réagi tous de
manière épidermique à partir du moment
où on se sont concernés c'est l'ego qui
répond ce sont les émotions qu'ils
répondent et la raison a besoin de
distanciation par rapport aux sujets
dont on parle donc la politique c'est
quelque chose qui me semble totalement
vains d'aborder dans le cadre d'une
discussion entre amis
parce que pour moi la politique c'est le
nouveau champ du sacré c'est à dire que
pendant des siècles et des siècles on à
fonctionner sur une religion qui était
le christianisme en france et à partir
de là révolution française la religion
chrétienne a commencé à décliner que ce
soit dans les esprits et dans la
pratique et à partir de là ça a été le
point de départ du réinvestissement du
sacré dans la chose politique
autrement dit ce n'est plus la religion
qui était l'objet du sacré c'était la
politique c'était la république c'était
les droits de l'homme et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il est extrêmement
difficile d'avoir une discussion sereine
avec quelqu'un qui ne partage pas vos
opinions politiques parce que tout de
suite cette personne-là va défendre ses
idées ses opinions
comme si c'était une croyance divine
comme si c'était un dogme religieux
qu'il ne fallait pas toucher et vous
verrez à quel point on retrouve dans les
discussions et dans les disputes
politiques les ressorts du sacré les
ressorts de la religion les ressorts de
ce qu'on défendra coûte que coûte
si vous commencez à discuter avec
quelqu'un sur la peine de mort sur le
mariage gay sur la pma et vous allez
voir que cette personne généralement à
la déjà un avis elle a déjà une position
est que si vous allez frontalement à
l'encontre de ses opinions
ça va être vraiment très compliqué
d'instaurer un échange serein échanges
apaisés et comment supporter les
conneries des autres biens ou chers amis
j'ai envie de dire qu' on est tous
l'autre de quelqu'un est ce que tu
appelles les conneries des autres il
faut bien comprendre que chacun a de
bonnes raisons de penser ce qu'il pense
et qu'avant de se dire que ce sont des
conneries
on peut aussi se poser la question mais
pourquoi est ce que cette personne pense
ce qu'elle pense et quand on fait ça on
pratique la philosophie quand on fait ça
on accepte que tout le monde ne pense
pas de la même façon mais que tout
penser à son historique toute pensée a
derrière elle un historique de causes et
d'effets mais qui va produire la pensée
qui s'expriment devant nous donc je
dirais que si je ne suis pas d'accord
avec quelqu'un et que si j'estime que ce
qu'elle me dit ce sont des conneries
eh bien je vais tout simplement la
laisser penser ce qu'elle veut je vais
lui donner mon avis et elle me le
demande mais je ne vais surtout pas
essayer de la convaincre ou de la
convertir à mon propre mode de pensée
qui sont suivante comment répondre à
ceux qui me disent que notre conscience
n'est qu'un sous produit de la masse de
matière qu'est notre corps alors ça
c'est une question que je vais traiter
dans une prochaine vidéo ou prochaine
vidéo que je vais sortir dans quelques
semaines je pense parce qu'il me faut le
temps de la préparer tout simplement
parce que je vais y aborder des
questions liées à la science notamment à
l'évolution charles darwin et c'est une
question qui m'intéresse
particulièrement parce qu'elle se
rapporte directement au rapport entre le
corps et l'esprit
alors que répondre à ceux qui pensent
que la conscience n'est qu'un sous
produit de notre corps en l'occurrence
de notre cerveau bien je dirais que
d'une certaine manière pourquoi pas on
peut considérer que la conscience n'est
qu'un sous produit du cerveau mais en
réalité ça ne
ça ne change pas les termes du
questionnement ça ne change pas les
termes de la réflexion pourquoi parce
que si on part du principe que tous les
organes dans un corps vivant que ce soit
les êtres humains ou les animaux que
tous les organes répondent à une
fonction eh bien on va se poser la
question à quoi sert la conscience
et la conscience elle sert tout
simplement à prendre en compte la
réalité qui nous entoure pour pouvoir
nous y adapter
et c'est cette complexité cérébrale qui
rend la conscience beaucoup plus
prononcée chez l'être humain que chez
les animaux
en réalité les animaux une confiance
limitée à ce qu'on appellera la
conscience immédiate la conscience
spontanée tandis que l'être humain a une
conscience beaucoup plus abouti puisque
l'être humain a conscience de soi et la
conscience de son existence
il a conscience de la mort et donc de la
temporalité de son existence
tout ça ça crée une différence une
différence notable entre la conscience
humaine et la conscience animale
il se trouve que parallèlement à ça la
complexité cérébrale de l'être humain
permet d'expliquer pourquoi cette
conscience humaine est beaucoup plus
aboutie mais moi la question que je pose
est qui me paraît finalement peut-être
plus intéressante et plus pertinente
c'est de se dire mais pourquoi
avons-nous cette fonction qu'elle a
conscience surprend la théorie de
l'évolution classique
la théorie de l'évolution de darwin on
s'aperçoit que l'organe est toujours
précédée par la fonction autrement dit
ce n'est pas la fonction qui dépend de
l'organe c'est l'organe qui dépend de la
fonction pour le dire de manière
vraiment très schématique
ce n'est pas parce qu'on a des yeux que
l'on voit c'est parce qu'il est plus
avantageux de voir que l'on a des yeux
ce qui se passe c'est que l'être humain
comme tous les animaux
il a une priorité qui est la survie et
pour survivre à l'environnement parfois
hostile dans lequel il se trouve il est
obligé de s'adapter et donc s'adapter
ça veut dire conserver ce qui est
avantageux pour l'adaptation donc
avantageux pour la survie est éliminé ce
qui n'est pas avantageux donc nous avons
des yeux parce que avoir des yeux est
avantageux pour la survie et d'une
manière générale nos cinq sens nous
permettent de nous adapter à la réalité
c'est à dire d'éviter le danger est
d'éviter la mort donc maintenant si on
se pose la question au niveau de la
conscience
à quoi sert la conscience parce qu'après
on pourrait dire que la conscience n'est
pas forcément un avantage évolutif
la conscience est aussi ce qui fait
qu'on va se questionner en permanence et
le questionnement n'est pas forcément
une bonne chose
du point de vue de la survie il ya des
situations où il vaut mieux agir plutôt
que réfléchir
et pourtant l'évolution a fait que
être humain a développé une conscience à
développer une conscience du monde et de
soi donc c'est bien qu'il ya une raison
c'est bien qu'il y a un avantage
évolutif à avoir une conscience qui nous
permet de nous adapter qui nous permet
de comprendre le monde et qui nous
permet aussi de coopérer les uns avec
les autres
parce que le mot conscience il a
plusieurs définitions et selon la
définition qu'on va prendre on va pas
parler exactement de la même chose mais
au niveau de la conscience comme
capacité à comprendre que l'autre existe
que je ne suis pas l'autre mais qu'en
même temps l'autre est aussi une partie
de moi-même
l'autre est en interaction permanente
avec moi et je ne peux me construire que
dans mon rapport et dans ma relation à
autrui
ça aussi ça fait partie de la conscience
et si ça fait partie de la conscience
ça veut dire qu'il est avantageux pour
l'être humain d'avoir une conscience
la question c'est peut-être de se
demander finalement qu'est-ce que cette
conscience peut nous apporter en termes
de coopération en termes de
mutualisation des efforts en termes de
fraternité entame tout simplement de
progrès mais de progrès réels pas le
slogan du progrès celui qui fait que par
nos efforts par nos volontés par nos
esprits on peut devrait à la création
d'un monde meilleur
et cette capacité que nous avons à uvrer
pour un monde meilleur
elle est directement corrélé au fait que
nous avons une conscience
voilà julien pour ma réponse un petit
peu longue question suivante pourquoi
vous avez choisi de traiter les idées
relatives aux mouvements optimiste alors
là je pense que tu fais référence au
fait que dans la plupart de mes vidéos
sur les philosophes il y a une approche
optimiste des idées dont je parle
bon en réalité ce n'est pas toujours le
cas il suffit d'écouter ma vidéo sur
schopenhauer pour se rendre compte que
on est loin de l'optimisme et que je ne
force pas schopenhauer à être optimiste
parce qu'il ne l'est pas en revanche tu
a raison de souligner que j'ai souvent
tendance et c'est volontaire évidemment
de ma part à mettre l'accent sur ce que
la philosophie peut apporter de positif
sur ce qu'elle peut apporter de bon pour
l'homme d'utile pour l'humanité si vous
voulez à ce niveau là j'ai une vision
très simple des choses c'est que face à
un même constat on peut toujours
justifier une approche pessimiste on
peut toujours justifier une approche
optimiste l'optimisme et le pessimisme
n'ont rien à voir avec les idées
l'optimisme et le pessimisme ont à voir
avec le tempérament et ont à voir avec
ce qui nous anime et moi ce qui m'anime
c'est la vie c'est pas là pitois mans
c'est pas le renoncement c'est pas
l'abandon ce n'est pas cette partie
sombre qui est en chacun d'entre nous
mais qu'on peut décider aussi de ne pas
suivre
je veux dire si on prend un exemple
concret par exemple vous vous lancez
dans une entreprise quelle qu'elle soit
et vous échouez pour des raisons pour
d'autres vous échouez vous ne parvenez
pas à atteindre votre objectif
bon qu'est ce que vous allez faire est
ce que vous allez passez votre temps à
pleurnicher à vous dire que le monde est
injuste à vous dire que vous aviez fait
exactement ce qu'il fallait mais que le
destin en a voulu autrement vous à les
accuser les autres vous allez vous
trouver des excuses est-ce que ça va
vous apporter quelque chose
est-ce que ça va vous faire avancer tout
simplement est-ce que c'est dans votre
intérêt parce qu'au bout d'un moment se
plaindre que les choses ne vont pas
accuser la terre entière
ça va bien cinq minutes mais honnêtement
à quoi ça sert à quoi ça vous avance
quel va être le résultat si votre
objectif c'est de souffrir et là dans le
malheur allez-y soyez pessimiste
maintenant si votre attitude c'est
d'avancer de vous dire que la vie est
courte et que on n'a pas le temps de
pleurnicher on n'a pas le temps de se
plaindre
et d'accuser la terre entière à ce
moment-là mécaniquement vous allez
devenir quelqu'un d'optimiste ou en tout
cas vous allez devenir quelqu'un de
pragmatique c'est à dire 2 neutres dans
votre manière de réagir à ce qui vous
arrive et c'est là où le stoïcisme est
une philosophie pratique qui permet ce
détachement dont je parlais tout à
l'heure
parce que lorsqu'on échoue généralement
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on a honte
c'est qu'on s'en veut occupa billy's et
quand on se plaint en disant que c'est
la faute des autres que c'est la faute
du monde donc c'est la faute du
déterminisme du destin le fait est que
on veut rejeter la faute sur les autres
parce que c'est beaucoup plus
confortable et bien sûr qu'il ya des
situations où nous ne sommes pas
responsables de ce qui nous arrive
bien sûr qu'il ya des choses qui
échappent à notre volonté et dont on ne
peut absolument pas assumer la
responsabilité mais ce n'est pas parce
que quelque chose d'injuste nous arrive
que le pessimisme va nous aider que le
pessimisme va nous apporter une
amélioration une solution le pessimisme
va nous enfermer dans l'aigreur dans la
frustration dans leurs sentiments et
leurs sentiments
c'est ce qui détruit l'homme c'est ce
qui le ronge de l'intérieur c'est ce
qu'ils empêchent de vivre c'est ce
qu'ils empêchent d'entreprendre c'est ce
qu'ils empêchent dose et c'est ce qui
les empêche de créer le pessimisme c'est
l'ennemie de la vie c'est l'ennemie de
la beauté c'est l'ennemie de la grandeur
le pessimisme c'est l'ennemi de l'homme
voilà pour cette réponse quelque peu
exalté mon cher marois comment es tu
arrivé à avoir une aussi grande
ouverture d'esprit pratique en croyant
déiste agnostiques athées question très
personnelle nous allons voir si tu joue
le jeu de la faq
alors je pense que tout ce que j'ai dit
auparavant va répondre à ta question
comment j'en suis arrivée à avoir cette
grande ouverture d'esprit bien tout
simplement
quand j'ai compris que je ne pouvais pas
penser à la place des autres que ça
n'avait pas de sens ce serait comme
vouloir que l'hiver ne succède pas à
l'automne ce serait comme vouloir que la
terre tourne dans l'autre sens ce serait
comme vouloir être le maître du monde et
l'ouverture d'esprit c'est tout
simplement le fait d'accepter qu'on
n'est pas le maître du monde
là où l'intolérance bien que je n'aime
pas trop ce mot là où la rigidité
psychologique qui est là aussi l'ennemi
de la philosophie
cette rigidité psychologique qui fait
que si l'autre ne pensent pas comme moi
je pense si l'autre pense mal c'est
qu'il est dans l'erreur c'est qu'il se
trompe c'est que c'est un idiot c'est
que je dois les ducs et je dois
l'éclairer je dois le guider vers la
lumière
ça ce n'est pas du tout ma démarche ma
démarche c'est de proposer du matériau
pour la pensée du matériau pour l'esprit
et on se serre on en prend où on en
laisse on en fait ce qu'on veut je
dirais pas vous demander des comptes sur
la manière dont vous avez utilisé mes
vidéos de philosophie et savoir dans
quel cadre vous avez mis en application
les concepts dont je vous ai parlé c'est
pour ça que je vais vous parler de
différents auteurs qui sont totalement
en désaccord les uns avec les autres et
si vous écoutez chacune de mes vidéos de
philosophie vous allez peut-être avoir
ce sentiment que je suis d'accord avec
tout le monde mais pourquoi est-ce que
je suis d'accord avec tout le monde
parce que j'estime que tout le monde a
le droit à la parole que tout le monde a
une légitimité à penser ce qu'ils
pensent et croire qu'il ya dépensé
légitime qu'il y a des pensées qui sont
tout simplement fausses
c'est le meilleur moyen de s'interdire
de comprendre les choses moi je n'ai pas
envie de m'interdire de comprendre les
choses parce que quand on fait ça
généralement ce qui se produit et bien
c'est qu'à la fin on se fait baiser
quand on s'interdit de comprendre les
choses on se met dans des situations on
se fait du mal on se met dans des
situations où se pénalise et moi je n'ai
pas envie de me pénaliser moi je n'ai
pas envie de me faire du mal inutilement
il ya peut-être un élément
complémentaire à ma réponse c'est de
dire que je ne vois pas les idées des
autres comme des absolus que je dois
combattre si je ne suis pas d'accord
avec je ne vois pas les opinions les
idées les valeurs des pensées des autres
comme des menaces comme des dangers
ce que je vois comme une menace ou comme
un danger c'est un comportement c'est
une attitude c'est une manière d'être et
on peut être beaucoup plus fasciste et
extrémistes on peut être beaucoup plus
intégristes dans sa manière d'être que
dans le contenu de ses idées on peut
être quelqu'un qui a des idées
politiques fascistes mais sans être
quelqu'un de dangereux dans la vie de
tous les jours parce que ce ne sont pas
des idées qui prennent le pouvoir qui
prennent des décisions
ce sont des hommes et ce qui est
dangereux c'est la conduite humaine
c'est le comportement
ce sont les passions humaines la
recherche de la gloire la recherche de
grandeur et la recherche d'absolu
ça ça peut être dangereux mais l'idée en
tant que telle n'est pas dangereuse
ce qui est dangereux c'est ce qu'on en
fait c'est la manière dont on va
l'utiliser pour servir le bien pour
servir le mal pour servir ses intérêts
pour servir les intérêts du peuple pour
servir le vrai pour servir le faux le
beau ou le lait c'est ça qui est
dangereux c'est cette part obscure de
l'homme qui a besoin de régner sur les
autres qui a besoin d'être maîtresses du
monde c'est cette part sombre cette part
obscure qui est en l'homme et qui a
besoin de régner sur le monde qui a
besoin d'être reconnus d'être adulé
d'être célébré et quand on a réglé ce
problème ce problème de la
reconnaissance ce problème de l' estime
de soi on n'a plus besoin de régner sur
les autres on n'a plus besoin d'exercer
un pouvoir
on peut se contenter d'être on peut se
contenter de faire ce qu'on a à faire
est de laisser les autres vivre question
suivante salut charles que penses tu de
l'amour des relations hommes femmes
couples que nous dit la philosophie
stoïcienne à ce sujet quels sont les
philosophes qui nous en disent le plus
alors sur la question des relations
hommes femmes
je vais me contenter simplement de cette
réponse
simple les relations hommes-femmes selon
moi sont d'abord des relations de nature
animale puisque après tout on a le b
très bien que l'homme est un animal
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi dès lors
qu'on parle des relations de femmes
on ne devrait plus considérer les
humains comme des animaux nous sommes
d'abord des animaux et leurs relations
hommes-femmes sont d'abord dicté par des
instincts animaux par des instincts
biologique que cherche l'homme dans la
femme que cherche la femme dans l'homme
chacun recherche ce qui lui manque
chacun recherche ce qui le complète
chacun recherche ce dont il a besoin
pour se perpétuer dans le temps pour
repousser les limites de la mort et pour
assurer une descendance viable car ça
peut paraître extrêmement démoralise ont
désenchanté
mais là dessus je suis finalement assez
proche de schopenhauer et également de
frédéric delavier donges est préfacé
d'ailleurs le livre sexe contre énergie
sur les relations hommes-femmes et pour
qui a un peu d'expérience dans ce
domaine là vous vous apercevrez qu'en
réalité cette grille de lecture est
extrêmement fonctionnel et que ce qu'on
appelle la masculinité et la féminité
qu'on appelle également le yin et le
yang dans une autre culture
c'est cette idée de polarité c'est cette
idée de complémentarité et il y a
effectivement des genres qui existe et
c'est genre on ne peut pas les ignorer
au motif que ce serait quelque chose
d'inégalitaire quelque chose de
réactionnaire non c'est genre existent
ils sont en grande partie déterminée par
le sexe
même s'il ne s'y réduit ce pas puisqu'il
ya des hommes qui peuvent être plutôt
efféminé il peut y avoir des femmes qui
sont plutôt masculine et il n'est pas
absurde de penser que les contraintes
biologique qui pèsent sur l'homme en
tant qu'animal ou sur la femme en tant
qu'animal vont induire vont produire des
psychologies différente parce qu'il ne
faut pas oublier que nous sommes
programmés par la nature pour survivre
et à l'échelle collective à l'échelle de
l'espèce survivre ça veut dire se
reproduire et pour se reproduire
il faut passer par l'acte sexuel et
notre attirance sexuelle vers l'autre
sexe procède directement de cette
programmation instinctive
inscrite au plus profond nous de nous
reproduire pour perpétuer l'espèce et
c'est ça qui fait que l'acte sexuel est
une des choses les plus bestial dans
l'être humain parce que c'est un rappel
de l'animalité c'est un rappel de notre
bestialité fondamentale en tant qu'être
biologique
c'est ce qui fait que l'acte sexuel ou
n'est pas représenté en public parce que
nous avons honte de notre animalité et
c'est seulement dans le cadre de
l'intimité que l'on peut assumer cette
animalité ce moment où la raison n'a
plus rien à dire ce moment où c'est le
corps ou c'est la passion c'est
l'instinct uniquement qui s'exprime
c'est parce que nous redevenons des
animaux lorsque nous faisons l'amour
qu'on peut dire que les relations hommes
femmes sont d'abord guidée par cet
instinct sexuel
cet instinct animal qui nous pousse à
nous reproduire quant aux relations
hommes femmes
or sexe hors production je dirais que
les hommes et les femmes
on peut être beaucoup de mal à se
comprendre mais qu'ils sont faits pour
devoir se comprendre qu'ils sont faits
pour devoir se compléter et de ce point
de vue là je n'ai absolument aucun
problème à dire que l'homme doit parfois
savoir écouter sa partie féminine
parce que c'est grâce à cette partie
féminine qu'il peut établir une
connexion une relation avec les femmes
de la même façon que les femmes doivent
accepter que l'homme soit conforme et
différemment que le rapport aux émotions
que le rapport au sentiment n'est pas le
même chez les hommes et chez les femmes
et toute personne qui a un peu
d'expérience en la matière c'est
parfaitement que ces catégories
elles existent ce ne sont pas des
fantasmes du patriarcat et ce n'est pas
discriminant de dire ça ce qui est
discriminant c'est de considérer que
l'homme ne devrait plus être un homme et
que la femme ne devrait plus être une
femme parce qu'à ce moment là ça veut
dire qu'on a honte d'être un homme ou
d'être une femme
ça veut dire qu'on considère que c'est
dévalorisant d'être un homme ou d'être
une femme ça signifie qu'on nie
totalement les spécificités qui font que
nous sommes différents et qui fait que
quand on est attiré par une personne de
l'autre sexe
et bien ce qui nous attire c'est
inexplicable ces mystérieux on peut pas
l'expliquer rationnellement c'est
quelque chose d'animal c'est quelque
chose d'instinctif et c'est ça qui ont
fait la beauté parce que l'homme est un
animal conscient et en lui qu existent
ces deux dimensions son animalité son
humanité son instinct et sa conscience
et c'est ça qui rend la relation femmes
magique question suivante j'ai beaucoup
aimé le podcast sur le stoïcisme prévoit
tu d'en faire un sur l'utilitarisme
alors mon cher alexandre j'ai déjà fait
un pote
sur l'utilitarisme que tu trouveras sur
ma chaîne charles robin qui est ma
première chaîne ma chaîne personnelle et
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour informer
vous tous qui m'écoutez que
progressivement je vais importées des
vidéos de philosophie sur ma chaîne
charles robin je vais les importer sur
ma chaîne le précepteur de manière à ce
qu'elle soit tout centraliser sur cette
chaîne parce que je pense que ce sera
beaucoup plus facile pour les retrouver
la tension est elle la clé nous
permettant de vivre mieux
oui je réponds oui fermement
catégoriquement l'attention c'est la clé
c'est la clef de l'apprentissage c'est
également la clé des relations humaines
parce qu'en réalité lorsque vous faites
preuve d'attention vis-à-vis de la
personne qui est en face de vous vous
lui donnez le sentiment qu'elles
existent réellement à vos yeux
et c'est ça qui va permettre à la
relation de s'établir mais de prospérer
sur des bases saines
la clé de la communication c'est prendre
en compte le fait que l'autre a des
raisons de penser ce qu'il pense de
sentir ce qu'ils sont et d'être ce qu'il
est et ça on ne peut pas le fun on peut
pas faire semblant
on peut pas être dans une fosse écoute
dans une fosse attention parce qu'il ya
quelque chose en nous qui ressent
lorsque la personne ne nous écoute pas
vraiment lorsqu'elle fait semblant nous
écouter l'attention c'est le fait de se
dire que la personne qui est en face de
moi a une valeur et que ce qui est en
elle a une valeur et que ça mérite mon
attention ça mérite que je lui accorde
mon écoute et bien souvent les problèmes
que ce soit entre les enfants et les
parents ou que ce soit au sein des
couples en général ça vient d'un
problème d'attention d'un manque
d'attention ou d'un sentiment de manque
d'attention qui fait que tous les autres
problèmes en découle donc la tension au
niveau de l'apprentissage c'est ce qui
fait qu'on va retenir qu'on va
mémorisées voilà pourquoi je rejoins
totalement idrissa berkane lorsqu'il dit
qu'être amoureux c'est le meilleur moyen
d'apprendre parce que lorsqu'on aime
quelque chose on s'y intéresse
naturellement aussi intéressant
spontanément on n'a donc pas besoin de
s'infliger une sorte de souffrance et de
discipline pour apprendre on apprend
dans le plaisir on apprend lorsque l'on
est intéressé par les choses donc il
faut d'abord créer les conditions de
l'intérêt pour ensuite pouvoir avoir
cette attention qui va nous permettre
d'apprendre de manière
si mal quel avenir pour l'intelligence
émotionnelle dans l'enseignement alors
ma chère amy j'aurais tendance pour le
coup à être un petit peu pessimiste par
rapport à cette question parce qu'il me
semble que le système même de
l'éducation tel qu'il est pratiqué chez
nous c'est à dire un enseignement
collectif on a des classes avec 25 30 35
élèves parfois pour un seul professeur
est donc cette cette infrastructure de
l'enseignement l'enseignement collectif
fait que le professeur est obligé
d'adapter son discours non pas à chaque
individu non pas à chaque élève
mais un profil général et qu'est ce que
j'appelle le profil général c'est le
profil de la rationalité
je vais m'expliquer chaque personne a sa
propre manière de ressentir d'éprouver
des émotions et de réagir à ce qui se
passe autour d'elle
c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya des personnes
plus sensibles que d'autres qu'il ya des
personnes plus brutal que d'autres parce
qu'il ya un tel éventail au niveau du
profil émotionnel que deux individus
auront peut-être des manières de réagir
totalement différente
en revanche pour parler de ce qui est
rationnel par exemple les mathématiques
on considère et on a peut-être tort
d'ailleurs de considérer mais on
considère que la raison mathématiques
est un modèle universel que c'est
quelque chose qui ne dépend pas de notre
profil émotionnel ça s'adresse à la
raison donc ça s'adresse à ce que tout
individu humain possède en lui et si
l'enseignement en france met autant
l'accent sur la logique la rationalité
les mathématiques c'est justement parce
que c'est le langage qui est censé être
pouvoir entendu par tout le monde c'est
le langage qui transcende nos
particularismes émotionnel le langage
rationnel fait que tout le monde est
censé pouvoir comprendre ce qui se dit
la rationalité c'est la mise à distance
de quelque chose de telle sorte que tout
le monde puisse avoir un point de vue
dessus évidemment tout le monde n'a pas
les mêmes facilités en termes logique en
termes mathématiques en termes
analytique mais tout le monde a la
capacité de raisonner de manière logique
de raisonner de manière mathématique
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que le
système cerveau gauche que le système
analytique dans l'enseignement est
aujourd'hui prédominant
et je pense que ça risque de perdurer
aussi longtemps qu on fonctionnera sur
un mode de transmission un mode
d'enseignement collectif question
suivante où en es-tu dans son projet de
fonder une école alternative questions
de david
alors où est ce que j'en suis pour
l'instant david je ne te cache pas que
c'est beaucoup plus difficile que ce que
j'avais cru au départ je m'étais lancé
dans l'aventuré de cette école
alternative de manière un petit peu
naïve un petit peu innocente mais c'est
aussi comme ça qu'on apprend un c'est en
tentant les choses en se rendant compte
que finalement elles sont beaucoup plus
compliqué que prévu
donc j'en suis au stade où pour
l'instant je suis plutôt en train de
travailler sur la constitution d'un
réseau d'enseignants qui serait apte
volontaire est compétent pour enseigner
un pour travailler dans cette école
parce que même si le principe du
bénévolat ne semble partir d'une bonne
intention a priori c'est quand même très
difficile de demander à des enseignants
de prendre sur leur temps pour pouvoir
donner des cours gratuitement donc là en
ce moment je suis en train de participer
à la co fonda sion d'une coopérative de
travailleurs dans le service à la
personne
donc le système coopératif pour ceux qui
connaissent ça permet d'avoir un rapport
au monde de l'entrepreneuriat qu'un
petit peu différent qui va reposer sur
la mutualisation des compétences des
outils et qui permet également de
proposer dans le cadre des services à la
personne des cours particuliers n'ont
pas gratuit mais pour des sommes
totalement symbolique à des familles qui
n'auraient pas les moyens de se payer
des cours au tarif normal et donc là
cette coopérative que je suis en train
de co fondé avec deux associés je n'en
fais pas la publicité sur ma chaîne
youtube ou sur mes réseaux sociaux parce
que je sais pas combien de temps ça va
prendre c'est énormément de travail
administratif où je préfère attendre que
ce soit fait pour pouvoir en parler mais
je vois cette coopérative comme une
sorte de première marche vers ce projet
ultime qui sera sans doute le grand
projet de ma vie de création de cette
école alternative
voilà pour toi mon cher david prévoyez
vous un jour de faire un débat avec
votre collègue youtuber philosophe
monsieur fille sur la place de la
philosophie au sein de notre époque
contemporaine par exemple
alors pourquoi pas je serai totalement
partant pour faire une collaboration
avec monsieur fille mais pour être
honnête je ne le connais pas
personnellement
nous ne nous n'échangeons pas en privé
je ne sais même pas s'il me connaissent
il connaît ma chaîne donc s'il me le
propose
j'accepterai avec grand plaisir
maintenant je ne sais pas si monsieur
filles apprécient mes vidéos parce que
on a des approches un tout petit peu
différente
c'est à dire que monsieur fille il est
plutôt dans l'exposition et la
vulgarisation des connaissances
philosophiques
là au moins j'aurai peut-être une
approche un petit peu plus sauvage un
petit peu plus libre de la philosophie
il m'arrive très régulièrement
d'enregistrer mes audio de philosophie
sans avoir rien préparé alors que
monsieur fier mon avis il prépare
parfaitement chacune de ses vidéos
d'ailleurs ça se voit elles sont très
maîtrisées elles sont très approfondie
et je trouve qu'il fait du super boulot
et d'ailleurs s'il m'écoute et bien je
le félicite pour son travail et je
l'encouragé évidemment à continuer
bonjour charles quelle est la différence
entre la rhétorique et la sophistique la
différence entre la rhétorique et la
sophistique c'est que la rhétorique
c'est l'art du beau discours c'est l'art
de manier le langage pour être
convaincant ou plus précisément pour
être persuasif c'est-à-dire pour obtenir
l'adhésion de celui auquel on s'adresse
donc c'est ça la rhétorique c'est l'art
du discours et de la persuasion
là où la sophistique ça va être l'art du
discours et de la persuasion mis au
service du faux mis au service du
mensonge mis au service de la
manipulation
donc on pourrait dire que la sophistique
est une branche de la rhétorique mais
c'est la branche de la rhétorique qui
assument de ne pas être à la recherche
de la vérité
donc les sophistes dans l'antiquité
grecque c'était des personnes qui
utilisaient leur habileté rhétorique
leurs connaissances leur maîtrise du
langage pour convaincre et persuader
leur auditoire
indépendamment de la vérité de leur
discours
donc le sophiste il va jouer sur les
émotions il va jouer sur les biais
cognitifs
il va jouer sur les illusions logique
pour créer un assentiment de l'auditoire
pour créer une adhésion au discours et
c'est ça qui le différencie
du rhéteur la rhétorique c'est un terme
neutre et la rhétorique elle peut très
bien être utilisé à des fins
constructive à des fins bienveillante à
des fins de justice moi ce qui me
dérange souvent quand on parle de la
rhétorique c'est qu'on a souvent
tendance à dire que utiliser la
rhétorique c'est déjà être un sophiste
alors que pas du tout ça pose en réalité
la question de notre rapport à l'outil
la rhétorique c'est un outil est ce
qu'on fait de l'outil relève de notre
responsabilité et non pas de celle de
l'outil une bouteille en verre
ce n'est pas fait pour se battre avec
quelqu'un mais il n'empêche que si
quelqu'un nous a mal parlé on peut très
bien lui fracassé une bouteille en verre
sur le crâne dans le respect de la
personne bien sûr et la rhétorique c'est
un outil dont on peut se servir de
manière bienveillante ou malveillantes
ce qu'il faut selon moi bien entendre et
accepter c'est que dès lors qu'on
s'exprime on a une influence on peut pas
y échapper
quand on s'exprime on a de l'influencé
que ce soit dans une direction dans une
autre on a toujours de l' influence
quand on s'exprime et quand on a admis
sa à ce moment là on peut choisir de
définir la direction de l'influent ce
qu'on va avoir et la rhétorique peut
servir à ça la rhétorique c'est ce qui
fait par exemple que vous allez pouvoir
faire parler quelqu'un qui a quelque
chose à exprimer qu'il ya quelque chose
à sortir vous allez pouvoir créer de la
confiance
un climat de sécurité qui fait que la
personne va se sentir à l'aise et va
peut-être pouvoir se confier à vous
alors si vous êtes dans une forme
d'injonction de brutalité rhétorique et
que vous sommet la personne de dire ce
qu'elle a à dire
vous allez créer l'effet inverse vous
allez créer un blocage la personne vous
allez justement là l'art enfermé dans sa
peur et dans son appréhension la
rhétorique elle sert à tout et elle sert
autant à faire le bien qu à faire le mal
tout dépend de la manière dont vous
allez l'utiliser alors à ce propos je
vous encourage tous à vous rendre sur la
chaîne de victor ferry où il parle
justement de ce thème de la rhétorique
et toutes ces vidéos sont vraiment
extraordinaires en termes de pédagogie
et en termes de compréhension de cet
outil qu'est la rhétorique est ce que
j'aime beaucoup c'est victor ferry
justement c'est qu'à la fin de chacune
de ses vidéos il envoie un petit message
aux spectateurs qui regardent sa vidéo
en lui disant parle exprime-toi utilise
la rhétorique approprient toi cette
liste parce qu'il n'y a aucune raison de
laisser cet outil aux méchants
ray platon question suivante des
techniques pour éviter le flux de penser
trop important alors là je pense que tu
fais plus ou moins directement référence
à ma vidéo être trop intelligent vous
rend bête où je parle de la pensée
compulsive et de cette cogitation
permanente qui nous empêchent d'être
heureux et et d'y voir clair
alors des techniques pour éviter le flux
des pensées je répondrai tout simplement
l'activité physique puisque lorsque tu
te dépensent physiquement ton cerveau a
beaucoup moins d'énergie pour cogiter
dans tous les sens et quelque chose
qu'on ignore c'est que le cerveau se
nourrit principalement de sucre il est
même l'un des plus grands consommateurs
de sucre dans le corps humain et que
lorsqu'on consomme du sucre c'est à dire
lorsqu'on a une alimentation moderne
industriel tel que nous l'avons presque
tous on accumule énormément de sucre qu
on n'évacue pas dans la dépense
énergétique physique et ça peut être
aussi à la source de cette pensée
compulsive et de cette cogitation donc
le sport le sport le sport est
généralement après une bonne séance
d'une ou deux heures on pense moins on
pense mieux et on est plus serein
question suivante peut-on réellement se
faire son propre avis sont s'affilier à
une pensée existantes
très bonne question frédéric je fais
partie de ceux qui pensent qu'on ne
pense pas par soi même on ne pense
jamais par soi même
et d'ailleurs quand je dis ça et bien
d'autres l'ont pensé avant moi la pensée
se construit toujours sur un héritage
on pense à partir de ce qu'on a lu de ce
qu'on a vécu de ce qu'on a entendu
et même lorsqu'on pense avoir une idée
originale une idée qui n'a jamais été
formulée
il suffit généralement de quelques mois
de quelques années pour la retrouver
dans un livre pour l'entendre chez
quelqu'un d'autre qui l'avais déjà dit
avant nous et c'est à ce moment là qu'on
se dit généralement qu'on n'est pas
grand chose et que on ne fait peut-être
que réactualiser des savoirs qui se
perpétue dans le temps et d'ailleurs
c'est vraiment comme ça que je conçois
mon rôle sur youtube
c'est à dire d'être un transmetteur et
le transmetteur par définition ils ne
créent pas le transmetteur il prend et
donne c'est ça son travail et c'est la
mission que je me suis donné
voilà pourquoi plus en accumulent des
connaissances plus on accumule
des lectures mais aussi du vécu parce
que j'insiste sur le fait que le vécu
est au moins aussi important que la
lecture plein d'un cumul de
connaissances et plus on peut penser de
manière juste de manière habile de
manière pertinente parce qu on se
nourrit de la pensée des autres on se
nourrit de l'expérience des autres et
c'est comme ça qu'on progresse
question suivante est-ce qu'on peut
s'épouser oui faut juste que j'en parle
à ma fiancée mais à priori il n'y a pas
de problème félicitations pour les
cinquante mille c'est amplement mérité
penses tu que le nombre d'abonnés peux
te causer un jour une forme
d'autocensure
ah ça c'est une question qui m'intéresse
alors la réponse va être direct non je
ne pense pas que le nombre d'abonnés
aura une influence sur le fait de moto
censurer tout simplement parce que
l'autocensure est quelque chose qui
m'est étranger par nature je vais
m'expliquer l'autocensure c'est le fait
de s'interdire quelque chose que l'on
pense parce que l'on a peur des
conséquences que cela peut avoir
moi je ne me situe pas du tout dans ce
logiciel là c'est à dire que quand je
pense quelque chose je pense que c'est
vrai et même si je me dis que je me
trompe peut-être
j'assume ce que je pense et je ne vois
pas pourquoi je devrais cacher ce que je
pense quand on n'a pas honte de ce qu'on
pense
on n'a pas honte de le dire si j'avais
honte de penser ce que je pense j'aurais
sans doute honte de le dire
et à ce moment là je pourrais peut-être
pratiquer l'autocensure
mais étant donné que ce n'est pas mon
cas étant donné que j'assume ce que je
pense parce que ce que je pensais le
résultat non pas d'une humeur non pas
d'une émotion qui me traverse c'est le
résultat d'une construction et d'un
processus permanent à partir de là je
n'ai pas à avoir honte de ce que je
pense donc je n'ai pas à m'autocensurer
le fait est que quand je parle en vidéo
je n'exprime pas évidemment totalement
la même façon que lorsque je suis avec
mes amis ou avec ma famille ou avec mes
proches parce qu'avec mes amis avec ma
famille je ne parle pas de philosophie
je ne fais pas des exposés sur nietzsche
ou sur schopenhauer donc automatiquement
le mode d'expression que j'utilise dans
mes vidéos n'est pas celui que j'utilise
au quotidien mais dans le contenu de ce
que je dis je n'attends pas d'avoir
cinquante mille abonnés pour surveiller
mes paroles et surveiller mes paroles ça
se passe en amont ça se passe au niveau
de la réflexion au niveau de la pensée
et quand je dis
quelque chose qui me semble idiot ça
m'emmerde donc je fais en sorte de dire
des choses que je pense pertinentes au
moins dans le contexte dans lequel je
les énonce question suivante
bonjour quelques mots sur michel onfray
s'il vous plaît alors michel onfray
c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai pu critiquer
par le passé dans les premiers livres de
philosophie politique je le critiquais
justement sur certaines de ses positions
politiques que je jugeais un petit peu
naïve parce que michel onfray a
longtemps été un défenseur de
l'hédonisme et je trouvais qu'il ne se
rendait pas compte que l'hédonisme sur
le plan politique
ça donne le libéralisme le libéralisme a
besoin que les individus soient
hédoniste c'est à dire qu'ils soient
dans la recherche de la jouissance
permanente
le libéralisme fonctionne sur la
sollicitation et l'exploitation de la
pulsion de désir et donc je pensais je
pense toujours d'ailleurs que se
prétendre anticapitalistes tout en
faisant la promotion de l'hédonisme
ça me paraissait au mieux très naïf au
pire très malhonnête je me souviens même
d'ailleurs que j'avais envoyé un mail à
michel onfray en lui parlant de jean
claude michéa qui selon moi a été la clé
de compréhension de ce problème de ce
problème de grille de lecture politique
libérale et quelques temps après alors
je ne dis évidemment pas que je suis à
la source de cette évolution mais c'est
vrai que par la suite je pense que
michel onfray a dû s'intéresser un petit
peu au courant philosophique
antilibéraux et qui s'est rendu compte
de certaines contradictions qui pouvait
avoir dans son discours politique comme
je les ai souvent dit l'hédonisme en
tant que philosophie peut se défendre et
peut se justifier sans aucun problème le
problème arrive lorsque l'on veut en
faire une sorte de recommandations de
programmes politiques ou là généralement
ont rejoint le camp des idiots utiles
c'est à dire de ceux qui prônent un
discours avec de bonnes intentions mais
qui finalement participent à notre
domination
tu connais le prononce l'acteur alors
oui je connais le prononce yater la
légende raconte qu'il a fermé sa chaîne
youtube avant même de l'ouvrir mais
c'est pas impossible qu'on entende
parler lui prochainement
alors bon vous pouvez pas comprendre la
référence qui est fait dans cette
si on part le rapporteur le rapporteur
que je connais personnellement que je
connais très bien et je vous invite
d'ailleurs à les voir sa chaîne puisque
le rapporteur il fait de la pédagogie
musicale
il vous apprend à analyser à décortiquer
la musique notamment de la musique rap
le caractère besoin de l'atmosphère va
être créée par un piano auquel on va
supprimer les autres fréquences un
accord tous les deux temps pour rappeler
une marche funeste et une mélodie
cycliques très répétitive pour donner la
sensation d'une boucle interminable on
va lui faire jouer une note portant et
rajouter du délai pour donner de
l'épaisseur
le d-day c'est ce qui permet de répéter
régulièrement un son à la manière d'un
éco pour compléter on va utiliser une
base très basse et je vous invite à
aller vous abonner en masse sur sa
chaîne d'ailleurs je serai très amusé
qu'il se retrouve avec une vague
d'abonnés d'un coup là qui viendrait de
cette vidéo
donc n'hésitez pas à les lui apporter de
la force à aller voir ses vidéos et à
l'encourager dans sa démarche d'ailleurs
vous me verrez très prochainement sur sa
chaise
voilà maintenant je n'ai jamais dans ce
combat je serai à la chine et tu seras
hector j'ai des mines de mes concurrents
sans effet et tu es un joueur de jeux
vidéo
si oui lesquelles mais certains ont-ils
une empreinte philosophique sur toi
alors j'ai beaucoup joué au jeu vidéo
quand j'étais enfant ça c'est vrai j'ai
commencé assez jeune à l'âge de 6 ans je
crois donc on de métro 92
j'ai eu ma première console de jeux
vidéo qui était la master system 2 pour
ceux qui connaissent pour ceux qui sont
de ma génération j'ai adoré cette
console j'ai passé énormément d'heures
alex qui de sonic shinobi ensuite je
suis passé à la game boy
je n'ai pas eu la nintendo la nes j'ai
eu la gameboy également des heures
entières à jouer à tetris à mario land
je me souviens ensuite j'ai eu la super
nintendo le pack street fighter ii turbo
puisqu'avant d'être un joueur sur
consoles il faut savoir alors ça ça peut
être intéressant pour pour expliquer une
partie de mon tempérament
quand j'étais enfant quand j'avais 5 6
ans ma mère parfois aller faire les
courses à béziers et elle me laissait
dans
de jeux vidéo d'arcade sous la
responsabilité du du patron qui était là
avec qui je m'entendais très bien et qui
me payer des partis et je jouais avec
des adolescents de 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans
alors que j'en avais 6 et généralement
je les prenais tout ce jeu les éclaté à
street fighter
à l'époque c'était le street fighter 2 1
n'ont pas le street fighter 2 turbo
j'étais une machine de guerre j'étais un
monstre de jeu totalement imbattable et
donc j'adorerais street fighter 2 street
fighter ii turbo et j'ai passé
énormément d'heures sur les jeux de
combat et d'ailleurs c'était lié à mon
goût pour le combat physique j'étais un
enfant un petit peu bagarreur j'aimais
bien me confronter à mes camarades et
notamment avec la marrade plus grand que
moi parce que j'avais cette confiance
absolue dans les capacités physiques de
pouvoir battre n'importe qui après la
super nintendo je suis passée
directement je crois à la nintendo 64
je n'ai pas eu la playstation tout de
suite je les ai eus après coup mais moi
j'étais de l'école nintendo j'étais de
l'école mario de l'école zelda
j'étais pas l'école lara croft tomb
raider ou final fantasy c'était pas du
tout mon truc j'ai été d'ailleurs trop
impatient pour tolérer un temps de
chargement lorsque je mettais le jeu
donc il était hors de question que je
joue avec des cd je jouais avec des
cartouches qui était beaucoup plus
solide voilà et puis après la nintendo
donc là on arrive au début de
l'adolescence j'avais 12 ans 13 ans j'ai
beaucoup jouer à mario à zelda ocarina
of time qui est sans doute le dernier
grand jeu auquel j'ai joué et ensuite
progressivement je me suis retiré des
jeux vidéo parce que ça m'intéressait
plus trop j'ai eu deux une puberté
précoce
c'est donc vers l'âge de 12 13 ans je
préférais écouter tupac et barry white
que jouer aux jeux vidéo voilà pour
cette réponse ça lui aurait dû des films
avec une certaine profondeur
philosophique à nos conseillers ou même
des films plus généraux alors oui je
vais je pense que je ferai ça à chaque
faq voilà lancé comme ça trois titres de
films qui m'ont plu qui m'ont marqué qui
m'ont intéressé alors celui là je pense
que je les ai déjà cités c'est
the truman show the truman show avec jim
carrey the truman show un film que j'ai
beaucoup aimée parce que c'est un film
qui à la fois un caractère poétique
bon c'est un film un peu mièvre on va
pas se mentir c'est pas très réaliste
mais il est intéressant au niveau de la
mise en scène au niveau de l'esthétique
même au niveau de la colorimétrie je
trouve qu'il a cette capacité à vraiment
recréer cette atmosphère d'irréalité et
de virtualité et sur le plan
philosophique qui te pose la question du
rapport à la vérité du rapport à la
réalité du rapport également à la
sincérité et du prix de la liberté
qu'est ce que l'on est prêt à sacrifier
pour être libre la liberté mairie tel
qu'on lui sacrifie tout un deuxième film
que je pourrais vous citer ses vols au
dessus d'un nid de coucou grands
classiques du cinéma avec jack nicholson
qui pose la question de la frontière
entre folie et normalité et de la
manière dont notre rapport à la folie
peut lui même conduire à la folie on
s'aperçoit à travers ce film ce que l'on
savait déjà qui est que la folie n'est
pas quelque chose face à quoi nous
serions tous immunisés et qu' on ne
bascule pas en réalité dans dans la
folie c'est quelque chose qui nous prend
et qui nous emporte sans même qu'on s'en
rende compte
et peut-être d'ailleurs que la folie
n'est n'est rien d'autre que le nom
qu'on a donné à cette incapacité que
l'on avait à communiquer avec les autres
qu'on appelle les gens normaux
le dernier film que je vais vous
conseiller c'est captain fantastic alors
captain fantastic faut savoir que quand
on m'a proposé de regarder ce film j'ai
jugé au titre que ça allait pas me
plaire du tout je m'attendais à voir un
marvel je m'attendais à voir un film de
science fiction et des avengers je ne
sais quoi enfin bref ce qui est pas mon
truc du tout est en réalité ça n'a
strictement rien à voir avec ça on ne
veut vraiment pas dans le même registre
captain fantastic c'est l'histoire d'un
père et de ses enfants qu'il a décidé
d'élever dans un mode de vie naturel ils
grandissent dans la forêt il se
confronte aux éléments ils apprennent à
se débrouiller tout seul et ce père de
famille avec ses enfants va être obligé
de retourner dans la civilisation pour
une raison que
que je ne vous dévoilerai pas ici
retournez dans la civilisation et se
confronter à justement la normalité et
c'est un film extrêmement touchant parce
qu'il pose la question à la fois de la
responsabilité parentale
ce que l'on fait avec nos enfants nos
enfants pourront un jour nous le
reprocher donc la question du dilemme
entre nos propres convictions nos
propres valeurs et la nécessité de
rendre nos enfants adapté au monde
ça pose la question de la responsabilité
parentale ça pose aussi la question de
l'engagement des limites de l'engagement
et ça pose évidemment la question du
sens que l'on donne à notre vie est ce
que l'on est prêt à vivre une vie que
l'on pense factice une vie que l'on
pense inconsistante que l'on pense
fausses jusqu'à quel point est ce qu'on
est prêt à vivre une vie qui a du sens
qu'est ce que ça implique et qu'elle en
ait loupé
voilà ce que je pouvais proposer comme
films qui m'ont particulièrement plu on
peut s'attendre à quoi sûreté prochaine
vidéo
alors on peut s'attendre à ce que je
continue les audio philosophie qui
manifestement vous plaisent beaucoup
on peut également s'attendre à des
vidéos justement de l'autre côté du
spectre des vidéos longue mais
travailler avec un gros travail de
montage
un gros travail de ce cryptage en amont
également parce que j'ai envie aussi de
me diversifier et puis j'ai quelques
petites réponses à apporter à des vidéos
qui ont été faites il ya maintenant
longtemps des vidéos de youtube heures
sur des philosophes ou sur des thèmes
philosophiques
donc ça fait longtemps que j'ai envie de
répondre à ces vidéos ou en tout cas
d'apporter un autre point de vue donc ça
ça fait partie des choses qui paraîtront
prochainement sur ma chaîne et puis j'ai
aussi eu l'idée est là je sollicite
votre avis pour savoir si selon vous
c'est une bonne idée de faire des vidéos
blogs
c'est à dire des courtes vidéos où je
parlerai de choses beaucoup plus légères
peut-être un tout petit peu plus
personnelle alors personnel attention
personnelle ne veut pas dire intime
personnel ne veut pas dire que je vais
ouvrir les portes de ma vie privée mais
en tout cas parler de choses un peu plus
légères un peu plus futiles et je me
demandais si vous si vous accueillir y
est ça de manière favorable
donc si l'idée vous plaît vous le dites
et puis peut-être que
à la fin de cette année je commencerai
les premiers vlog et c'était la dernière
question on a terminé cette faq
je remercie parce que vous m'avez posé
des questions très pertinentes qui m'ont
permis parfois de de me répéter sur des
choses importantes
et puis d'ouvrir sur des choses
nouvelles je remercie pour votre
attention je vous remercie à nouveau
encore une fois pour votre soutien pour
ceux qui veulent me soutenir je vous
rappelle que vous avez plusieurs
manières de le faire la plus importante
et la plus efficace c'est de partager
des vidéos
parce qu'à chaque fois que vous partagez
une vidéo sur vos réseaux sociaux
dites-vous que trois quatre ou cinq
personnes vont la regarder et donc
mécaniquement barça va entraîner une
augmentation de la visibilité donc
n'hésitez pas à partager les vidéos
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
n'hésitez pas également à les commenter
et pour ceux qui veulent aller encore un
peu plus loin dans leur soutien vous
pouvez passer parti pis vous pouvez
également passer par le système des
souscriptions
les souscriptions vous accéderez en
cliquant sur le bouton rejoindre sous
mes vidéos ne l'est pas nous rejoindre
sur les réseaux sociaux facebook
instagram twitter tous les liens sont
dans la description on se retrouve très
prochainement pour de nouvelles
aventures
et d'ici là comme d'habitude soyez sages
[Musique]
oh